[Musik]
tokio was für eine stadt gerade noch saß
ich im flugzeug und jetzt dass menschen
menschen menschen mein name ist patrick
rohr bis vor ein paar jahren war ich
moderator beim schweizer fernsehen
heute bin ich als fotojournalist auf der
ganzen welt unterwegs
hier in japan möchte ich ein buch mit
bildern und texten dieses land machen
ich bin froh habe ich einen
reisebegleiter deniz can sich ein
japaner
der vater ist schweizer die mutter kommt
aus japan aufgewachsen ist dennis in der
schweiz
er spricht aber auch japanisch und er
hat eine zeitlang in japan gelebt darum
ist er für mich nicht nur sprach sondern
auch kultur übersetzer in japan sieht
man nicht einfach so dahinter
bis man nur schon die vielen behalten
sie legen begreift wir finden es ja zb
unanständig wenn man beim essen schlüpft
in japan ist das normal
nur so entfaltet sich der volle
geschmack des essens im mund erklärt
mehr dallas
ich kann mir vorstellen dass diese reise
sehr spannend wird ich freue mich auf
das abenteuer
[Musik]
man sagt ja japan sei eine insel das
stimmt nicht ganz japan besteht aus über
6.800 inseln liegen im pazifischen ozean
die nächsten nachbarn sind russland
china nordkorea südkorea und taiwan
meine reise startet in tokio der
hauptstadt japans zehn millionen
menschen leben hier
42 millionen sind es im großraum tokio
tennis hat mir empfohlen fernzusehen das
japanische fernsehen sei es eher lustig
es ist lustig und irgendwie auch
ziemlich vertraut tatsächlich die junge
frau im heidi kostüm ist haut schweizer
im hau die japanerin ihr name christin
haruka sarah christin ist in japan ein
großer star
sie ist eine tiefe personalität jemand
der in den verschiedensten rollen im
fernsehen auf krebs als moderatorin von
spielshows aus talk gast aus kultur und
politik kommentatorin haruka christin
ist eine spannende person mit 16 ging
sie von zürich wo sie aufgewachsen ist
nach japan in das heimatland ihres
vaters allein ohne eltern
ich wollte sie gerne kennenlernen was
ich selbstverständlich ist bei und
terminkalender
wir treffen uns in einem park in tokio
ein ruhiges gespräch mit ihr zu führen
ist fast unmöglich die leute im park
sind völlig aus dem häuschen
das könnte auch damit zu tun haben dass
jetzt die kirschblüten zeit beginnt
warum ist das ausbrechen der kirschblüte
in japan etwas besonderes die
kirschblüte selbst sieht man nur eine
woche lang und das bedeutet frühling in
japan
es ist genau die zeit in der das
schuljahr aufhört und wieder anfängt und
das setzt man einfach mit einer decke
auf die diese feiert und trinkt bis in
die nacht hinein
ja man hat spaß ist pizza zum beispiel
nein ich geboren was hast du lustiges
gesagt
sie blühen noch nicht zu sehen
und was haben sie gesagt sie sehen sehr
viele blüten vermutlich wegen des
alkohols doppelt so viele
ich bin überrascht bevor ich hierher kam
dachte ich die japaner seinen ruhiges
kontrolliert das volk vielleicht sogar
ein bisschen zurückhaltend und jetzt
erlebe ich wie sie ausgelassen feiern
und sogar am helllichten tag 1 über den
durst trinken
ist der bahnhof dort hinten ja ja genau
gar nicht richtig wenn es uns
fotografieren gibt scheint man hier
ohnehin keine scheu zu kennen
wir gehen in einen rahmen
ich habe grossen das ist typisch
japanisch dass sich der automat hier
muss man bestehen wir geben jetzt die
bestellung ja hier kommen die ticket
1000 2000 man zahlt also und dann wählt
man das was man möchte
das ist mit nudeln nachschlag
das ist nur dran es ist alles dabei wenn
man noch mehr will kann man hier drücken
reicht das ja praktisch einmal dass er
für mich ein freund einmal ein
ich war da schon wieder komplett
aufgeschmissen steht alles auf japanisch
dass sich die freien plätze
mir gefällt das besondere an ihm ist man
kann sehr gut allein kommt man sieht
nicht wie die anderen essen und das hier
das ist wasser sehr praktisch das finde
ich so genial in japan man denkt immer
an alles
das ist er an du hast die nudeln zwar
bestellt aber noch nicht wie du die
noten haben willst das kann ich jetzt
aufhören und dann hier speziell ist man
sieht die leute nicht und sie sehen uns
nicht schüchtern japaner können allein
hierher kommen und schon bringt ein
gesichtsloser kerner die suppe sie sagt
man kölner die man nicht sieht gäste die
sich abschotten ein besonderes 3g man
sich in japan überhaupt aus dem weg ich
habe nämlich auch schon gehört dass man
in japan keine meinung haben
viele haben ihre meinung aber sie sagen
sie trotzdem nicht weil sie vielleicht
angst haben dass andere eine
unterschiedliche meinung haben könnten
und sie dann nicht mehr gut auskommen
miteinander dass der ganze mensch
irgendwie abgelehnt wird genau also
nicht nur die meinung die stimmung ist
sehr wichtig was meine herum passiert
die stimmung lesen ja ein lehrreiches
ersten la rocca christin
wir gehen noch ein haus weiter
und jetzt zum schluss gehen wir noch
einen typisch japanischen ort
das blaue dort wieder das blau und dh
[Musik]
danke
am abend will media nisters tokioter
nachtleben zeigen bevor er begonnen hat
aus dem titel designer bei einem lauf
schuhproduzenten zu arbeiten hat dennis
in japan zitiert und eine zeit lang auch
hier gearbeitet
er weiß wie man sich in der stadt bewegt
ist es eigentlich sicher hier
ich habe ich trag mainz hinten in japan
geht das finde ich sie sind sehr streng
hier
die strafen sind drakonisch du findest
ein gesicht wenn du zum beispiel klaus
und alle wissen dass dann ist eine
familie erledigt verrückt weil die
japaner ein großes
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl haben gibt es
dinge die man einfach nicht tut stellen
zum beispiel die angst vor dem
gesichtsverlust hat also durchaus ihre
vorteile
perfektion ist ein rotlichtviertel von
tokio geben hier nur aus wenn man auf
der suche nach dem rotlicht ist es gibt
auch gute was man kann und was trinken
gehen hier am rand von kambodscha liegt
golden goal das alte prostituierten
viertel die prostitution wurde in japan
ende der 1950 er jahre verboten
heute sind da wo früher die modelle
waren bars einige hundert schön
ineinander verschachtelt und meist nicht
größer als ein wohnzimmer
größer
hier gefällt es mir es ist klein die
drinks stammgäste haben ihre eigene
flasche aber jeder gast hat seine eigene
flasche angeschrieben mit dem namen des
gastes
wenn ich hier gast wäre dann hätte ich
meine eigene flaschen würden jeder nach
trier kommen
nicht jede nacht vielleicht einmal pro
woche oder zwei mal
ich habe heute gelernt dass ich es so
betonen arbeitest oder gehört das ist
nicht nur eine bahre
ich habe zwei jobs ich verkaufe
secondhand kleider und arbeite hier du
verkaufst kleider die kleiderkauf ich in
den usa bringe sie hierher und verkaufe
sie online
reister so viel ja ich besuche meine
verkäufer jedes jahr
[Musik]
heuer seien sehr teuer
in den usa kostet dieses shirt ein bis
zwei dollar in japan fünf bis
sechstausend yen 50 franken
50 dollar ducati also 52 dollar und
verkaufte 5000 es ist ein geheimnis
du bist ein guter verkäufer you go ist
mir sympathisch gerne würde ich ihn
fotografieren am liebsten bei ihm zu
hause dann sehe ich auch gleich wie
jemand wie erlebt ich frage mich ob wir
zu hause besuchen dürften er sagt ja
dennis ist überrascht dass man in japan
jemand zu sich nach hause einladen sei
sehr ungewöhnlich
normalerweise findet das sozialleben
außerhalb tragen vier wände statt sagt
er
guten tag wie geht es gut ich wieder zu
sehen jeweils 37 seit ein paar monaten
wohnt er wieder daheim bei seinen eltern
und das ist der laden
das ist das was du online verkaufs
nachts in einem webshop verkaufen und
alles ist aus zweiter hand das leben in
tokio ist sehr teuer
darum hat juwi viele japaner zwei jobs
das ist anstrengend aber noch viel
anstrengender war sein autos leben aus
er immer als büroangestellter manchmal
konnte ich nachts nicht nach hause ich
arbeite in der firma und schlief in der
büro am schreibtisch so echt und dann
morgen aufwachen weiter arbeiten ja oft
wie lange macht es du das
vermutlich acht jahre acht jahre etwa
acht jahren jetzt hatte mehr freizeit
aber auch mehr freiheit aber es gibt
dinge die als selbständiger nicht
möglich sind
eine eigene wohnung zu kaufen zum
beispiel ohne festes einkommen geht das
in japan nicht dafür lebte mit seinem
webshop einen großen traum
wie findest du das weißt du was wo liegt
ja ich erinnere mich du hast du so ein
system ohne ein system zu haben ein
system nein kann ich dir helfen
ja ich kann einpacken und jetzt das
shirt ich muss die adresse schreiben
kann ich probiere besser zu schreiben
ja auf japanisch ich kann versuchen
alles sind das chinesisch oder japanisch
zeichen war das ein mix japanische
zeichnen aber ursprünglich aus china
sehr gut gemacht ich glaube der name
reicht es mir zu viele verschiedene
zeichen kannst du die adresse schreiben
[Gelächter]
was wird ein kunde denken ist am 18
wir verstehen uns gut
ich frage mich ob ich ein paar fotos von
ihm schießen dürfe so ernst jünger
daheim das gibt ein aussagekräftiges
bild ein ganzes leben in einem bild ich
wünsche dir viel glück mit deinen job
und in der wahl gemacht etwas das in der
japanischen gesellschaft nicht viele
leute wagen
er geht seinen eigenen weg dennis hat in
tokio ein grosses beziehungsnetz er
möchte mir einen freund vorstellen
der sei sehr fotogen erst vor einer
woche herbert an der mister japan
teilgenommen
das schicke schwarze auto
heißt mit vollem namen yuki takahashi
erst 26 jahre alt und der sohn eines
fischhändler wohnt eine autostunde vom
zentrum entfernt
richtig glücklich ist er mit seinem
leben nicht er würde gerne anders leben
glanzvoller auch jogi hat zwei jobs
er arbeitet am promo standard des
autohändlers und im geschäft seines
vaters verkauft hat ein paar tage die
woche fisch die idee ist dass yuki das
geschäft der einst von seinem vater
übernimmt
ein hübsches geschäft das ist eine
cousine ich bin patrick ich bin fotograf
[Musik]
weil er so gut aussieht so sehr beliebt
bei älteren dame und deshalb verkauft
sich auch dafür ist besser das
fischgeschäft von jogis vater ist ein
paradies für fischliebhaber und das
zünden japan ja praktisch alle menschen
[Musik]
er wirkt sehr entspannt und natürlich
das gefällt mir dass computer
[Musik]
er wirkt ganz anders vor der kammer
krass wir packen noch ein paar fische
ein und machen uns auf den weg zu ihm
unterwegs frage ich ihn
aber eigentlich nie ein profi modell
hatte werden wollen doch sagt er aber
sein weg sei wahrscheinlich ein anderer
denkst du dein vater wartete von judas
zu den fischen übernimmst du möchtest du
von dir aus weiterführen
ich muss den laden nicht direkt wegen
eines vaters übernehmen
aber meine eltern haben das geschäft
aufgebaut
ich fände es schade wenn es nicht
weitergehen ich möchte es weiterleben
lassen und dann meine kinder weitergeben
als familien vermächtnisse viele
menschen in japan würden von einem
anderen leben träumen erzählt mir der
nichts aber schließlich entschieden sich
doch die meisten für den traditionellen
weg
wie viele unverheiratete menschen lebt
auch er noch im elternhaus
zusammen mit dem vater und der
großmutter die mutter ist von einem jahr
an krebs gestorben
[Applaus]
sie freut sich immer auf sie wäre sie
froh wenn er so moringer geworden ein
kandidat ist der stolz ist sie stolz
dass ihr enkel hier mitgemacht hat
sie hat sich sehr darüber gefreut
[Musik]
wir machen aber das ist ein
traditioneller japanischer eintopf yuki
nimmt dazu zusammen dass muscheln und
garnelen aus seinem geschäft huhn pilze
und gemüse
wenn ist
[Musik]
wow
und das heißt das heißt ich nehme das
essen an bedanke mich beim koch und in
meiner sprache
[Musik]
die metropolitane region um tokio ist
die größte der welt
42 millionen menschen leben hier und das
auf einer fläche die nur ein drittel so
groß ist wie die schweiz
und es kommen immer mehr leute nach
tokio
viele suchen den ruhm
sie hoffen idol zu werden stars oder
nehmen in japan sagt heidel
zehntausende junge frauen und männer in
tokio hoffen auf diese art berühmt zu
werden
ich würde gerne hinter die kulissen des
japanischen pop business schauen
endlich bekommen die möglichkeit eine
gruppe zu treffen die schon ein bisschen
weiter ist dass sie
[Musik]
kam endlich kamen auf deutsch heißt das
die maske mädchen in ihrer biografie
steht dass sie die masken als zeichen
des protests gegen den schönheits- und
jugendwahn in der popindustrie tagen
wördehoff war von dieser geschichte dran
ist dieser mann muss es wissen ist er
manager von carmen schoss er bringt uns
zu einem der etablierten mitglieder
seiner band erinnert
er ist 25
gleich vier manager kein kostüm gefällt
mir und sind dass die schuhe die
dazugehören und die quietschen so lustig
neben kevin schmidt heute auch andere
starlets das heißt sie sind sehr beliebt
das bist du wie ist das für dich auf
einem magazincover zu sein
[Musik]
sie freut sich sehr dass das gesicht des
magazins zu sein ist eine große ehre für
sie sie freut sich weil sie so viel
machen darf er ist ganz deutlich besser
auch seinen job dort wo kein talent ist
so aussehen zu lassen als wir etwa den
vorhanden
das ist die größte waffe ihre masken der
visuelle eindruck der masken ist sehr
stark identität aufgebaut die man
wiedererkennt sind das ist ihre waffe
nummer eins wir müssen zum nächsten ort
gehen
die masken sind also vor allem ein guter
marketing-gag kein protest
der dienstag startet in akihabara einem
etwas heruntergekommenen beliebten
vergnügungsviertel in tokio
die hat job ist nicht gerade das finde
ich ist das könnte auch für uns sein
sie machen fotos vielleicht erlebt sie
das tatsächlich so intensiv sind nicht
nur sängerin sondern auch models für
werbungen der erste job heute ist ein
werbespot für eine firma die virtual
reality brillen verkauft wie hat sie das
erlebt war in einer völlig anderen welt
2 von elenas kolleginnen war und messer
kommen dazu zusammen posieren die drei
masken mädchen in ihrem grünen gelobt
wir haben jetzt mit dem belieben kamen
josh figuren
es geht weiter zum nächsten auftrag
die zweite station an diesem morgen ist
ein made café eine beliebte attraktion
im viertel
heute machen wir werbefotos für diese
touristenkarte von aqaba die kameras
kannte das publikum also durch das
viertel
genau mit ihren empfehlungen kamen
georges sind jetzt mails dienstmädchen
werden tun sie mir leid
viel zeit für mitleid bleibt allerdings
nicht
der nächste auftrag ein
spielzeuggeschäft ich frage mich ob die
jungen frauen sich bewusst sind worauf
sie sich einlassen wenn sie sich für
eine karriere auf ebbo entscheiden
dein beruf gibt mir die möglichkeit
deine träume auch wirklich zu leben aber
es ist auch ein ziemlich harter job
körperlich ist es oft anstrengend aber
es gefällt mir ich habe spaß an dieser
arbeit meine motivation treibt mich an
[Musik]
ohne pause geht es auf den höhepunkt
eines jeden kamen george tags zu den
auftritt in halle die das management für
die auftritte von karin schmid einen
lohn gibt es nur für die ältesten mit
geben die über 20
und auch der ist nicht hoch 2000 franken
im monat dafür sagte manager bekam kamen
josh eine ausbildung und sie seien
versorgt die masken mädchen wohnen
nämlich im haus des managements
zeit für ein privatleben bleibt er nicht
er immer sagt ein partner oder gar
kinder kämen für sie im moment nicht in
frage kannst du auch noch nach dem
landtag
sie schaue zwar völlig rein aber
irgendwie habe ich trotzdem eigenartiges
gefühl die mädchen fangen zum teil schon
mit neun jahren wohnen im gleichen haus
wie das management zusammen mit anderen
mädchen
wie muss ich mir das genau vorstellen
geben die eltern die kinder einfach ab
und die sind dann tage nach bei euch die
ganze woche
ja so ist es
wir übernehmen die verantwortung für die
erziehung anstelle der eltern müssen
heute abend noch eine modenschau machen
[Musik]
das sieben tage die woche
ich schaute da für die gesundheit der
jungen frauen nicht alle arbeiten jeden
tag die neunjährigen nur einmal pro
woche arena ist momentan sehr viel
beschäftigt und arbeitete
wir helfen ja auch wenn sie zum beispiel
zeit braucht für eine massage oder zeit
zum essen
erinner hatte eine augenkrankheit und
wir haben einen guten arzt für sie
gemacht
wir kümmern uns gut um unsere mädchen
mein gefühl bleibt die mädchen werden in
diesem business behandelt wie eine ware
das einzige was mich ein bisschen
versöhnt ist die stimmung hinter den
kulissen
hier geht es zur ihm klassenlager und
das hat ja irgendwie auch etwas
fröhliches
[Musik]
sind das menschen oder maschinen
[Applaus]
die stimme aus dem off stellte richtige
frage
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch dem vorwiegend männlichen publikum
ist das in dem moment wahrscheinlich
egal
das darf sich jetzt einfach gehen lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
höhepunkte kopf die ersten tage in tokio
waren sehr intensiv ich habe 1000 neue
eindrücke und die letzten nächte waren
sehr kurz
ich bin froh haben dennison dich schon
früher beschlossen nach der ersten woche
in tokio ein paar tage ins land zu
fahren
im gewühl des bahnhofs china gewann
suchen wir den weg zum shinkansen dem
japanischen hochgeschwindigkeitszug der
auf einem eigenen schienennetz bis zu
320 stundenkilometer schnell fährt vor
dem einsteigen machen wir es wie die
menschen in japan
wir kaufen eine bento box eine kleine
schachtel von lokaler spezialitäten pkw
auf japanisch das ist sehr gesund und 14
schweizer franken auch recht lästig
[Musik]
du darfst nicht so nahe zu stehen
der shinkansen ist ein wunder zu auf den
zentimeter genau da wo es auf dem
bahnsteig eingezeichnet ist ist die tür
zum einsteigen
und auf die sekunde genau fährt der zug
auch wieder ab dieser geht das nicht ob
japanische art ist man immer im kreis
von unten links oben rechts
ich würde beim reis anfang ist alles
sehr fein
man muss man salz ich mal so ich liebe
es du musst immer im kreis essen um die
zunge wieder aufzufrischen bis salzig
[Musik]
langsam entspanne ich mich ich denke
zurück an die intensiven tage und nächte
in tokio und die menschen die ich in der
verrückten stadt kennengelernt und
fotografiert habe
haruka christin der japanische fernseh
star
judo der zweitjobs macht um sich über
wasser zu halten
der job ein kandidat der verkäufer ist
charitos die für ein kleines bisschen
blumen einen hohen preis bezahlen
[Musik]
von tokio sind wir mit dem zug nach
teuer mal am besten gefahren
jetzt sind wir mit dem auto unterwegs
ins bergdorf 1
leicht übermüdet und im linksverkehr
kannst du mir aus meiner jackentasche
eingeben
ich habe einen hungerast du bist du die
dinger rein gefahren war es in die
pfosten auf der linken seite auf der
linke sieht das gar nicht sein schaut
der spiegels verschoben was du bist
reingefahren
ich habe es gehört bumm bumm hat gemacht
und auch das japanische navi ist
gewöhnungsbedürftig wenn alles schief
geht und dort müssen wir ändern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir übernachten dem privaten haus einer
gastfamilie einem minijob inbegriffen
sind hier übernachtung das abendessen
und das frühstück breakfast auf
japanisch wie in allen traditionellen
häusern in japan schläft man auf einem
foto auf dem boden der mit tatami matten
ausgelegt ist
in meinem zimmer versteckt sich hinter
drei schranktüren noch ein aufwändiger
buddhistische schreien alle haushalte
wir sehen in den meisten japanischen
häusern gibt
sie sagt das zimmer mit dem hausaltar
das sei das schönste
plötzlich streckten man den kopf durch
die tür es ist hiroshi yamazaki mal muss
man mir gefallen sein haus sage ich ihm
und er erklärt mir ein paar eigenheiten
der rauch stieg hoch und schmerzen so
dass holz alu holz firma und anderen
schädiger hinweg alles aus holz kein
einziger nagel nicht ein adler und das
hält sogar das dach das ist kein strom
sondern vom cover einer nuss aber es
werden schichten darauf gelegt dass wird
der ruf geschichte das scheint ein gutes
material zu sein
die dächer isolieren hervorragend sie
haben den schnee ab und sind wasserdicht
es ist kalt
in den japanischen häusern gibt es keine
heizung nicht einmal in den bergen aber
verlieren wir es mir in der nacht
trotzdem nicht aus dem feuer in dem
marie denn fisch fürs abendessen brett
nimmt sie ein stück kohle und legte es
in einem ton behälter
wir schlafen wunderbar
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen schneit es eine gute
gelegenheit um eine der vielen heißen
quellen zu besuchen einen sogenannten
konzern hier hingehen viele japanerinnen
und japaner für tägliches wasch und
badet uhr hier im vorraum machst du dich
bereit siehst dich aus dass kleines hoch
kannst du mit ihm dort musst du dich von
kopf bis fuß waschen bevor wir ins bett
gehst du hast ein tattoo
warum in japan ist das schwierig wenn du
einen tag geben es wird mich in yakuza
also mit der japanischen mafia also das
haben nur die bösen
es ist auch verboten ja aber du kannst
es versucht ich wage es zum glück sind
an diesem morgen auch nicht viele leute
im bad
das waschen ist wichtig dabei wird nicht
nur der körper sondern auch der geist
gereinigt erst wenn man ganz aber ist
geht man ins heiße bad ein schönes
ritual und man kann sich dabei wunderbar
entspannen
[Musik]
wir sind bereit für die fortsetzung
unseres abenteuers in der nächsten folge
reise in die küstenstadt onagawa im
nordosten des landes
die stadt wird neu aufgebaut 2011 hat
der zunahme ist komplett zerstört
[Musik]
man sagt von den japanern sie seien aber
charles und sehr effizientes volk wie
war das ist kann ich gleich erleben wenn
ein shinkansen geputzt wird
und ich treffe eine starke frau
joker motto sie zeigt mir dass ein kilo
nicht nur sport auch eine philosophie
ist
[Musik]